[Music]
this is me just after being born and
this is me just before sitting the final
exam of my PhD in mathematics a few
things happened between those two
effects so the final exam of the PhD is
called a Biver short for viber watch a
viva voce meaning a spoken exam so
unlike basically every other exam I've
taken in education from age 4 to age 27
I wasn't gonna be assessed based on my
written responses to set questions I was
going to be assessed based on how I
talked about something specifically
talking about this this is my PhD thesis
snappily titled quasi GS terrific
influence at the polar stratosphere on
the troposphere and while I will make a
video about this in the future sort of
in detail talking about the science
until all the science in it has been
published I'm not gonna do that so that
will have to wait but for the time being
suffice to say it's about physics in the
atmosphere the virus serves a few
purposes one to determine if I actually
wrote this to determine if I understand
what I wrote and three if I can answer
questions about how my work fits into
the broader work on the subject into the
literature now here's the kicker
Viper's are slightly different all over
the world but in the UK they consist of
you a room a world leading expert in
your field an academic internal to your
university and no time limit well
actually my university recently
installed a time limit so I knew that
the whole driver had to be done in less
than four hours four hours of answering
questions about your work from a world
leading academic so I had some
preparation to do here's me two days
before the VIPRE I've reread my thesis
twice now and I've been making notes on
I think likely questions that kind of
come up and now today I'm going to
continue because I've been doing this
for on and off the past couple of days
I'm gonna go back and reread papers I'm
going to practice some derivations that
they might ask me to do I'm gonna get
default answers ready for a couple of
questions it's actually very difficult
to know how to prepare for
this because I didn't know what they
cannot ask I know the thesis backwards
like nobody on earth knows this thesis
better than I do
it's a question of what angle they take
and I can maximize the probability that
I will be able to answer their questions
by thinking of answers to them the most
likely ones but I know I'm gonna get
blindsided ah what kind of powerless
something that I'd like to emphasize
here is that it's amazing to me that I
am in this situation like as a kid
academically I wasn't anything special
when I went to secondary school which
was my local state comp I was described
as having a scatty
approach and specifically a mess I was
making good progress but I needed to
guard against unnecessary distractions
in class I've never found math easy or
intuitive I mean it was actually the
subject that caused me the most grief
for the first years of school and so
like any kid in that situation I would
get distracted
I would chat I would not want to do the
difficult thing but something happened
between year 7 and year 11 then my maths
report for that year there's this really
nice quote I continue to be most
impressed by Simon's conscientious
attitude his study and its determination
to succeed there are occasions when he
finds difficult concepts challenging but
he is always ready to ask to the help he
needs
to be honest I don't think I'm a
particularly clever person I do stupid
stuff all the time but if there's one
thing that's got me from that point in
year 7 to where I am now frankly it's
just not giving up ok so a bit of an
update it's now later I have been
working all afternoon on fiverr prep let
me show you my desk my atmospheric
physics textbook incidentally if you're
interested in like the basics I'd
recommend this one this is the second
edition of woloson hops and then behind
that is my actual thesis and I was
actually just looking at some stuff to
do with transfer economics but you'll
also notice is that I've got these tabs
on the side so these are for the
different chapters you know so I think
chats for actually starts on the other
Hey
yeah so Vanessa quickly gets chat for
then there's that and then there's also
these which are key tabs for
particularly important results and then
over here in the workbook I've been
doing some practicing derivations and
I've been going through things like
deriving qgp VD trying trying to derive
Earth's helpp wish they'd have to be
really sadistic to ask me about I spent
way too long actually going through that
and then realizing you know what this is
a bit obscene so I've moved on I've done
a couple of pages of um other derivation
and I'm gonna keep doing this for about
another hour or so and then I need to
move on to do some YouTube things like
writing scripts I just dropped my pen
like writing scripts editing that yeah
new chibi things and then all day
tomorrow guess what I'm doing to link
the story up to the present day I after
secondary school I went to Oxford to
study physics which again I'd still it's
kind of unbelievable to me that that
happened because my local state school
the state comp had never sent anyone to
Oxford to study physics before and no
one in my family had ever even been to
uni before I went to San Peter's College
which of course is the best college at
the University and a dog stood I got
specifically interested in atmospheric
physics after I took a course in
geophysical fluid dynamics which is the
physics of how large-scale fluids like
water and air move on the surface of a
rotating planet which that's so cool
look at the geostrophic equations those
are two equations that describe how
massive fluid air masses move in
responses to changes in pressure like
how cool is that
so I did my Master's Oxford and then I
was actually offered a place to do a PhD
there but that didn't happen so it is a
day before v-day this morning I've been
looking through some papers then I've
also been continuing book work in
particular taking notes on this paper
which I've taken notes on like twice
before but it was written by one of the
guys who is examining me my external
examiner actually here is the body the
main examiner so I think it's important
I understand it because it's relevant to
my thesis and it'll probably come up and
I don't want to look like
read it because I have read it several
times I just wanted to rush myself other
than that I'm gonna reread my thesis
again and I'll do the same tomorrow on
the train down to Exeter and I might
practice a couple of derivations again
you know try to hold an entire phd's
worth of background information in your
head at once not the easiest I don't
even know how many papers I've looked up
now I mean the back of this thesis own
pillows it's the back of this thesis is
one two three four five six seven yes
eight pages of bibliography and I
basically need to be able to talk about
well certainly the key ones there are
some papers which you're throwing is
like oh I'm talking about that statics
there's like a it's really this is
Griffiths read that textbook and then
some of them are like this is why it's
overly simplistic to say that the
principal mode of variability in the
troposphere is the mean latitude of the
Jetstream like I need to actually know
about paper backwards this is a lot just
about holding it together if you want
more details about this then you can
check out my draw my life video but
basically in my Master's year in my
final year at Oxford I got into a very
very bad place and I worked myself
completely into the ground totally
burned out and then instead of getting
help for my then rapidly unraveling
mental health I doubled down and I
worked and worked and worked and worked
and worked and I went into my final
exams severely sleep-deprived and
extremely depressed and having
self-harmed and I of course did terribly
so terribly in fact that I missed out on
the relatively easy condition required
to get my PhD place confirmed at Oxford
and so I was I was cut adrift that or
the offer was withdrawn and I spent a
summer not knowing what I was going to
do with my life
alright it is the night for my visor
alright it is the night before my visor
I spent all day looking through papers
looking through kind of key questions
that might come up and what I'm gonna do
now obviously at 10 o'clock
before bed as I'm gonna finish rereading
the thesis there's best part 100 pages
to read and I'm going to quickly skim
through never split the difference about
Chris boss which I talked about in my
book club basically being a great book
to read for getting more out of personal
negotiations and then month I don't know
there might be a couple of useful things
in it that might help me tomorrow but at
this stage it basically comes down to me
getting on a train tomorrow going to
Exeter and talking about my work I think
I know the thesis well I think I know
the theory behind it well if they asked
me to derive some of the equations in it
you know key for the background I can
they asked me to read arrive my
theoretical results I can do so I think
I'm ready I don't know if anyone ever
really knows if they're ready though
it's like getting married or going
abroad on deployment if you're in the
military for the first time you know
like I've read about it I've heard what
other people's experiences have been
like but I don't really know what to
expect I think I'm doing this under the
best circumstances like kid so whatever
happens I think basically done the best
I can which is a nice situation to be in
by a stroke of extreme luck my meant to
be supervisor at Oxford knew that
another academic at the University of
Exeter was looking for a PhD student and
they both agreed those good enough to do
a PhD and that they they thought I
deserved another chance and so I was
offered this place to study at Exeter so
despite having never seen the campus
before or knowing anything about the
University other than some of the
research that was going on in my
department I moved down and I loved it
if you haven't seen them already
I made vlogs of my entire experience of
Exeter from the beginning to the very
end there'll be a playlist linked down
there in the description and somewhere
up here on the screen and a car during
my time extre I was super aware that I
was given a second chance and so I threw
myself into everything you could do as a
student I did music student radio sport
research outreach traveling but more
than that I was singularly determined to
reward the faith that my supervisors
have put in
and produce work that was good enough if
I failed to if I failed to produce
academic work academic contributions the
word to standard I would be failing them
and I'd be failing myself and that's of
course would be determined by the Viper
so it's less than an hour until the
Viper now I've eaten I've kind of gone
through my mental checklist of all the
last thing is the check and I reread my
notes and I read the thesis and practice
the spiel that you give at the start
when they say so tell me about your
thesis I've done that I guess this is it
here's how the vibe went down I arrived
about 20 minutes early because I was
terrified of being late and I checked
the room number fifty times and then
eventually the academics turned up said
hello went straight in the room they
confirmed for 5-10 minutes and then they
invited me to come and sit down
now I didn't film the Viper because I
can't but that's basically the reason
why I didn't do it I know that I think
it was sixty symbols filmed there Viper
but it was again would have gone against
University regulations I don't think the
examiners would have wanted it and also
I wouldn't have wandered it because I
wouldn't want to relive the terror
because if you ask people that have gone
through the Viper system what it was
like they will say that it's terrifying
and enjoyable no I don't know about you
but those aren't two emotions that I
would frequently put together it turns
out that what those people mean by that
is that the Viper is terrifying and then
it gets enjoyable eventually and then it
gets terrifying again the terror set in
almost immediately after they've done
the soft warm-up question of so tell me
about your your thesis what have you
learn that's new anybody can answer that
and then after that they asked me to go
up to the whiteboard and talk through a
few things and draw some diagrams and
some equations and specifically they
wanted to know about something called
the brewer Dobson circulation now I know
about the Brad Dobson circulation it's a
quite an important process in the
stratosphere which is where my research
was taking place but I had a complete
mental blank and they kept prodding me
and I only kind of stumbled through the
answers after they kept sort of prodding
and how
helping me and hinting along I felt like
there was going very very badly
after that things improved and the Terra
kind is subsided as we went from the
background chapter to the theory stuff
I'd done I mean the way that the viber
works is you just go through your thesis
page by page by page and little post it
by posted that the examiner has put in
their copy and you just going through
everything that they thought was
anything that was wrong anything that
wants discussion and as that happened
and you went in to the original stuff
that I've done it became enjoyable or
certainly more enjoyable because at the
end of the day this is the only time I
will ever have a conversation with
anyone who was read my entire thesis and
understands it and you know they
understand they understand it in the
context of the literature so when people
have in the past have said to me I
enjoyed my viola I get it in the middle
of going through my results we came to
the section on my ppm version code now a
longtime viewers of the vlog know just
how much pain and suffering that code
caused me and so I was really quite
worried when they got to that point and
asked me to explain what I'd done over
several pages a few key plots just just
there like just talk talk me through
this what have you done here and that
either meant that I'd done it wrong or
they really misunderstood what I'd done
across this whole section of the thesis
neither of which would have been good
news but the Viper carried on until the
end of the thesis we've got to the last
page closed it we talked about the
implications of the research for sort of
current thinking on the subject and then
they were like thank you you like to
step outside and so I waited outside for
5-10 minutes or they made a decision and
the terror came back I was very
conscious in those 10 15 20 whatever it
was minutes that this was it this was
the finale of my 23 years of education
from
cute and adorable in primary school
teenagers awkward and then uni and
failure and then I hoped Redemption I
can't tell you how slowly those minutes
went by and then
I passed I have a PhD I'm now gonna cut
to me about an hour after I finished the
fiver to talk about the verdict in a
little more detail so they were like we
were very happy to say that you know you
have passed you are we're gonna give you
the PhD they didn't give minor or major
Corrections basically they have a tick
box it was like how long do you think
they need to do these Corrections and
they said we're gonna to the six-month
correction box not because we think you
necessarily need that much time
you could do this in three months which
is the other option but we'll just give
you a bit more time from what needs to
be changed based on that Corrections is
a couple of extra sentences in the
background dealing with how my work fits
into the existing work so that's not
very much work and then there's also a
little bit of extra analysis which is
rewriting some code that I've already
written with an extra dataset basically
just comparing it which is kind of got a
pivot how positively the whole thesis
feels you know how positive the the
results are because they were like you
know you've done stuff here which is
really good it's just you're presenting
in a very negative way so just do a
little bit of we need obvious analysis
really think if you take along and then
you know it's gonna come out so much
better so they're like yeah you know
we'll give you six months to do that
that tick box sound like you know if you
were asking you to do a little bit of
extra analysis even if it's really
simple like that sounds like this tick
box but there's really I came into this
being like if I get major I'm gonna be
disappointed but they emphasize that
really there's no difference between
major and minor Corrections any more
like if there if there ever was it's
just a question of how long you need so
I prefer if there was a less that needs
to be added to the thesis but I think
they they seem to be they thought that
the conclusions are really cool the
takeaway from it they were like I've not
seen that before that's really cool
you've kind of disentangled this
phenomenon from the existing literature
and like you've identified this as the
same thing that's really interesting
they know they've they're like
developing just showing how it's kind of
developed through the literature any
understanding of it so they they seem to
enjoy reading it and they feel that
scientifically was interesting so I'm
happy I mean I'm really quite happy
about I'm not the only one that's done
though so this is Tom who we started up
here it's doing the same day to 2013 and
there we are both pH done we have so
we've just spoken for the roommate here
you had like a month between submission
doing the Bible eat that yes I submitted
for the very beginning of December
saying yes the same day as you and I
have my Bible on 4th of January I didn't
really get Christmas break or anything
yeah I at least have a little bit longer
but we're now with both my supervisors
like a proud parent now could be like oh
we've had the two kids they've grown up
and they've gone on you're now working
here at the unity it's you're still not
really oh sorry there is a difference if
you see Tom around dudes guilt death yes
he'll be wearing one of those say hi
because he's great and I'm gonna now go
and go to the pub and I did indeed go to
the pub but you're not seeing that
footage so as of a week ago I am now
subject corrections doctor Clark which
is insane yeah that's the bananas to be
complaining saying and I want to say to
anyone who's watching this who's
struggling with studying at school or at
uni that if there's anything you can
learn from this story from from my
example it's that the single most
important thing you can be as a student
is determined yes it's not enough to
just blindly plow hours in to working
and it's not enough to just have the
discipline to sit at your desk every day
you've got to work smart and you've got
to actively engage with the material
you're learning but the single most
important thing as a learn
is to put the work in if you don't work
then neither will any of your carefully
constructed plans you've got to be
willing to put the work in and never
give up
refusal to give up academically has got
me to where I am now despite of my
intellectual shortcomings that's the end
of this vive err story and just like to
repeat as I said in my thesis hand in
video thank you so much to everyone who
has supported me here on YouTube online
your never-ending support really really
carried me across the finish line so
from the bottom of my heart
thank you in many ways this PhD belongs
to all of you
- it doesn't it belongs to me I the
person who gets it but in some ways
metaphorically we all learn this but
mostly me if you're new here and you'd
like to check out all those PhD blogs
then click up here if you would like to
know what I'm doing next then click up
here and if you'd like to subscribe to
this channel and be alerted for all the
great videos which are coming up and
believe me there are some great ones
coming up then click the link here thank
you very much for watching and I'll see
you next time